hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Red Dead Redemption
- now this is the episode where I go
hunting and I ain't gonna hunt around it
the first place that I need to go is
apparently right here because in this
general area there is what is known as
the trapper and the trapper is what I've
been looking for this entire time the
guy that's gonna help me get the recipes
that I need to be able to make what I
want to make and that may include a
certain possum at now I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to do that but I'm
gonna go all the way over there and I'm
going to kill every animal I see my god
it is foggy out here also I feel like I
have to sneeze okay thank you okay I'm
better now I think no no I bet I've been
having this constant feeling that I
needed to sneeze for a while and that
finally paid off in dividends I think
it's the fogginess of this area so we're
you having entered legendary animal
territory but it will take some time
before the animal returns to the area oh
because I didn't do it as the it's a
legendary Fox but whatever it don't
matter it don't matter it don't matter
ooh hello you okay there we are
I got that dig gift yeah so in the
meantime we're just gonna be sitting
around chill and chat and enjoy and the
no one we're gonna be enjoying the
lovely lovely lovely lovely lovely
environment and talk about some stuff
and we want to talk about yeah oh so a
while back I was talking about my trip
to Korea how I realized it I I have a
lot of stories from Korea but I never
really got around telling him I always
thought that I would find a place to do
it when I'm in a game but I always ends
up being like god dammit this XYZ
happens and I can't do nothing about it
but now I can so it's nice and one of
the one of the greatest things about my
trip to Korea was just the ability to
appreciate this part of me that I've
never really embraced before and I've
said that before but like it really
really really met
meant a lot to me this is because like I
am half Korean for those of you who
still don't know somehow I am half
Korean yes and when I was growing up as
a kid you know I didn't really get a
chance to embrace any of that it wasn't
just a part of my child it wasn't any
any sort of that you know as a kid
growing up in a small town called
Milford in the middle of Ohio you don't
get a lot of reinforcement about your
cultural heritage so it ends up you just
kind of do whatever you can to not stand
out nearly as much and kind of fit in
where you can sorry didn't mean that
yeesh okay well I got one
I kinda anyway kind of beat up a little
bit but that's alright yeah so but when
I went to Korea like one of the things
that I really noticed isn't so much that
like I I didn't really identify with all
of the it's not like that I super
identified with the culture or anything
like that because it's super hard to say
that and do that when this is the first
time I've gone over there for
appreciating it but what I did realize
is that I could I felt like I could I
felt like it could really be a part of
it and I felt like I wanted to where as
I was starting to learn Korean just to
try to learn Korean for the sake of
speaking with my family I want to now
learn Korean for the sake of kind of
living in Korea and one of the best ways
that I could possibly do that is by
going over to Korea and living there for
at least a little bit of time hello okay
hi how are you doing what is this are
you looking at oh I'm sorry yeah none of
this in front of me is weird right now
no I'm sorry
I'm ruined ruined oh so it's a disaster
who wants to see a woman wrangle wild
animals who doesn't have any bloody wild
animals come to America they said come
the land of opportunity
they said soft you daddy I said I'm
going to America to make it on the stage
I didn't want to be in the army now look
at me the old git will have a field day
understand act the bravest woman in the
world the animal Wrangler watch her tame
wild beasts and you were the one of
course I was the bloody woman look at me
it's the stage grease paint tears no one
wants to see a man wrangling wild
animals and no one wants to see a woman
wrangling nothing can I borrow your gun
I want to shoot myself
you see I'm buggered what my animals
they escaped and now I'm I'm buggered
what escaped of priceless Rendon aqui
tiger from the slopes of Hindu heights a
fantastic elusive zebra from the plains
of unga-bunga by the shores of the
Limpopo and a magnificent lion from the
grasslands of Tanganyika yeah see your
problem they're pretty hard to come by
around here listen friend help a fellow
out would you I'm beyond desperate if
you see any of them will you bring them
back here if I see a tiger exactly if
when I believe the zebras apnea along
its own distinctive creature that he is
I'll make it worth a while all right
it's bloody Margaret not madam okay I'm
not doing that there's no way in hell
I'm gonna help you Margaret but maybe
not right now maybe I will eventually
because that's amazing but at the same
time I already have a mission for this
and it's hunting down different animals
and
I have a funny feeling you wouldn't be
appreciative if I murdered all your
animals so I'm not gonna do that
hello hi there hello what again again
again
what the heck in heck what the heck in a
queue just let's go I think my
controller might be broken because I've
dropped it and probably thrown it at
some juncture or another hey can you
come back here come on now no don't let
go don't let go man you could impale me
real easily with those okay yeah so was
I talking about oh yeah so I feel like I
could really go to Korea like go there
enjoy the land enjoy everything about
Korea really learn the language and
immerse myself in the experience of it
like if I live there for about two
months I figure that's what I want like
you know and I don't know exactly how
I'm gonna work for it but uh you know I
say that but obviously it would be a lot
easier for me to do then pretty much
anything I could just go there I have
family there that would take care of me
and I could stay with them or I kind of
want to live on my own just to see like
would be like to live in Seoul and I
know the whole renting system is weird
over there so I got to deal with that I
think I can only care one of those maybe
yeah I'm gonna see it again gee I've
been so I've been so like I don't know
I've been so in my own bubble as far as
living on YouTube I think this is like
personal stuff like I've been in so in
my own bubble and I sometimes forget
that I can just do whatever I want like
whenever I can
okay what was that city is asked for a
harmonica oh oh
even know that yeah so like I could I
could go like I could leave well I got
tour I got tour but like if I had some
free time I could just like go find a
flight same day go out there bring some
recording equipment and make some
make some videos while I'm there can you
get over you looked there we go can you
get over a little closer please a little
closer yeah family that's besides the
point the logistics of it aren't exactly
what I was talking about but yeah I just
I really like the culture of it I really
feel like I could be part of it but then
again I've also got the option the funny
option that in LA there's this place
called Koreatown and you can
legitimately just oh yeah you can't do
it okay well forget this how do I drop
you yeah you can only do one of those at
a time but an unlimited number of
pellets so I could I could just like go
to Koreatown everyday and just kind of
hang out there which could be fun yeah
but at the same time I'm not sure if it
would be entirely the same experience
but I mean Koreatown is I miss Koreatown
so you wouldn't be too far off from the
general experience of it again again
okay why cuz it automatically hops off
the horse one that does it so it's not
like I have a choice it just gets too
far away and then suddenly it's gone I
will join you but I don't want to take
my weight off in that weird way that you
suggested me to there's a lot of options
that I can do and it's it's all it's all
leading into like what I want to do in
the next decade of my life because next
year I'm gonna be 30 years old I'm gonna
hit the big 3-0 and I kind of wonder
like what am I to be doing after that I
know it's not in any way shape or form
old but it will feel old like her I'm 29
I already feel old Bonin comes down to
it comes down to living like the next
decade of my life I really do wonder
like how is it gonna shape up what one
of my pursuits gonna be like what am I
gonna what I got what am I gonna be
focusing on and I'm gonna be focusing on
like trying to improve the videos that I
make cuz I'm probably gonna be doing
YouTube for the next few years at least
in one shape or another and just like
what's that gonna be like do I want to
go and make some movies which I could do
like see how that goes do I want to try
to start a business of some sort like
what am I gonna be doing to my 30s
because my 20s are largely defined by
what I did on YouTube I started my
youtube channel when I was 20 to eat
just before I turned 22 years old like
23 years old so I was like 2 months away
from 23 years old I started my channel
so from 23 to 30 was all that I do and
all that you see right now and then I
know what's what's 30 to 40 gonna be
like what am I gonna be like when I'm 40
yeah I can't even imagine that I mean I
have a pretty good idea of what I'm
gonna be like when I'm 30 at least I'm
gonna be moderately healthier cuz I've
started running lately and for some
reason I never thought that I would but
I like running I just enjoy it it's
something that I can actually get behind
so I feel healthier and I feel like I'm
actually getting in shape I feel excited
when I get ready to run and even after
I'm done running I'm like oh boy I wish
I could run some more which is an
experience that I never thought I'd ever
have but I'm not worried about my health
I'm not worried about all that I've had
enough healthy peers in my 20s I'm sure
I'll have more health care soon but yeah
it's just like what am I gonna do
purpose wise because a lot of what I do
on YouTube is very purpose-driven I feel
I feel like a lot of what I've done and
what we've done is the community has
accomplished a lot in terms of helping
people and spreading a lot of goodwill
and I wonder if it's gonna carry on in
the same way that it's been done or if
there's gonna be some new form that I'll
have to explore you know what I mean I
don't know where it's gonna lead and I
don't know how I'm gonna get there but I
know that I'm gonna keep working at it
and all I can do is be curious about it
yeah oh wait that's the trapper that is
that is the trapper hey buddy hey how
you doing hey Fred hey no no no how you
doing
listen I'm good those are less good come
on where's all the fur hats oh hell yeah
oh my god
that is amazing Oh God I oh god the Fox
one oh that's so terrifying it's so
[Music]
funny okay god that's vast oh oh not bad
I don't think I have any perfect hides
at all yeah I don't think I have any of
those garment sets the bear oh my god
Oh Marga legend oh wait wait wait I can
get that right now cuz I killed that leg
dad that's what it said I thought it
said that it kept my legendary Bear pelt
I've got three of those bad boys oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I'm putting that hat on my head
I'm never letting it go because it's my
favorite hat slightly warm pair with
other warm items for protection against
the cold nope I'm good always wearing it
never taking it off oh my god I am so
happy I am the happiest man look at my
hat
this is great about this agree to say my
love this greatest man my life I've
never had a greater life day than today
nothing's a problem man nothing at all
let me show you this man oh man am I
happy about this I'm trying to do some
business with you man come on come on
man
okay I'm gonna keep the perfect deer
pill cuz that's good for crafting i'ma
get rid of everything else okay that's
some good money not that good money
you're a blowin well I'm gonna I'm gonna
hop out of here before you start blowing
me so have a good day I thought that
this was going to be a different
adventure where I was going to have to
hunt down a special beaver and get a
special beaver hat or a possum hat but
this turned out much much much better so
happy I am so happy
okay so let me uh I guess I'd go back
wait I got there's ma what is MA
margaret was market for Oh
Margaret's two zebra should be here okay
let me go for bebe black Bell on the way
here cuz it's right there so I'm a I'm
as well take care of black bebe
as I go by I'm so at you guys don't
understand
because number one things never work out
for me like this things absolutely never
100% work out for me like this so to
have just this fall in my lap where I
have the bear Pell / already the
trappers got it I get my hat
that's all I wore no wait no oh God okay
that's fine
I got my hat though okay come on so long
as I got my hat I was so worried I got
my hat we're good let's does not fall
off any mountains I gotta stop going off
the trail because every time I go off
the trail bad [ __ ] happens to me so if I
can stay on the trail everything's gonna
be good I'm gonna be a happen man
everything's gonna be fine
I'm a happy boy I'm a happy boy so I
want it like the way I pictured it with
my life and what I've done thus far the
YouTube channel
[Music]
why should I help you if you've got the
pox that don't sound okay Oh what the
hell
well that's not gonna work for you and
in the back of the head and oh okay
thank you for that
and I'll take you back everything that
you just did for me
I meant to I I thought I hit the button
when it told me hit the button but was
like these are these are mechanics that
I've never seen before so wouldn't no
one knows everything
oh these guys really do have the box
though maybe I shouldn't be touching
them I don't know if that's the thing
that can happen in this game hey take
from the rich oh hey art a Parsi who is
this some stuff okay I don't know what
this is but I got some of it oregano all
right let's keep going what was I
talking about
oh yeah if you think about like from 23
to now like the YouTube channel has been
my big project
whereas everything inside the channel
has been smaller projects different
things that I do but the overarching
theme of my 20s is that I made a YouTube
deal like that is the overarching theme
so I'm like wondering like what is the
next 10 years ago my life gonna be I
know thankfully like thankfully I I know
thankfully that um like I'm probably
gonna be able to have the freedom to do
whatever I want which is not something
that everybody can say and I know that
I know that I should never take that for
granted because I never will and I never
want to forget like the people that
helped me along the way like the friends
that were there for me and you guys who
supported me the entire time that's
something that I can never forget but I
also wonder like what what next thing am
I gonna try to make myself improve that
what what next thing am I gonna try to
build myself up about what next thing am
I gonna conquer like what am I gonna do
cuz me as a person I'm very much defined
by the goals that I put in front of me
I'm very much built up by like the
challenges that I see on the horizon
very much like encouraged by the next
thing that I could possibly do and I
always look at it like that really cool
yeah and so when it comes down to
hopefully having something more down the
road I would only want to do that if it
was fulfilling it was challenging and it
really pushed me as an individual and it
made me take risks because it being
where I am and all the success that I
have like on the counter side of that is
like all having all that success makes
it very difficult to push myself in a
way that makes me risk everything I'd
like to talk to you about your Wild West
days I don't care much for reminiscing
you got any friends as bounty hunters
none that spring to mind you like my hat
well then you don't let them boys
hearing you none the wiser ah those
bounty hunters run out sooner or sooner
I'm good in shot I'll tell them you're
gone oh no no I'm hiding from them scalp
hunters running from them neither I'm
fighting it's just me against him I'd be
a waste of time a nitroglycerin
let me know what I can do you want that
wow we're story don't you yes alright
get up here quick
now when I give you the word hit that
black Bell oh we friendly soon attract
here for your life or your Liberty we'd
sooner it be Liberty that's mighty
reasonable mr. oak a dime out of I'm out
of debt I long they're trying to flank
us are they trying to flank us how many
of these guys they got oh gosh we got a
lot more than I thought they might wait
we're here pits put what but horseshit
Wow and a lot of people suddenly came
after you all at the same time no wonder
I didn't why did you even let me up to
your front whoa [ __ ] that's not that's
not good oh good thing I had a little
bit of dead I left like detonate this
lover I love her so much the only
running he did was away from a fight and
that's about the end of it
man's apparently a famous gunslinger
yeah so they say but don't get what's
famous confused with what's true the
ones of us have lived that life we was
too busy being scared for our scalp to
talk to new newspaper writers or Nam
novel man those days they all talk about
hmm famous now I guess only longer ago
all right I'm gonna need your picture to
say into trouble no sir no trouble at
all it can't be worse than us awful
drawings on the wall in posters oh great
you stand over there this thing ready oh
hell yeah oh hell yeah good stuff oh
good stuff
Oh ruining for 20 years
suppose I'll be runnin till I drop just
say it is if you ever want to do I don't
want a crew we got a goddamn she was
awesome what the hell why are you gonna
leave nobody so cool you are so cool
that's it oh my god she was so cool
well what was that what the hell just
happened all right then
man they're just gonna introduce a
character that cool and just she's gone
like just like that that is outrageous I
can't believe that that is so cool I
hope we see her again I really always
hear again because that was amazing
oh oh oh God
Oh oh god oh god oh he is in the mark
all right you know what I don't feel too
good about looting these buys mostly
because they're horrible and covered him
and the many types of [ __ ] okay anyway
back to waxing philosophical about my
cuz um like I've talked about before I
don't think that I'm gonna be doing
fried just damn it I was chips trying to
live oh my god there we go health tonic
thank you I need a second to real just
all right let's get back to town let's
go see what's going on over here boy
yeah so I know for a fact good I'm
probably gonna be playing video games in
one way or another until the day I die
like video games are an integral part of
my life but I also don't know if I'm
gonna be doing Let's Plays until dad
like who knows what kind of content
people will be making or watching like
in the next 10 years and just to just to
like be all like I'm old like just
looking at the technological
advancements of the last 10 years alone
that
like living just seeing how far things
have come from that like this cell phone
era that only started in oh seven it's
2018 that was just over ten years ago
now not the self of the smartphone era
it's like seeing how that's happening
now that's like move forward and I can't
imagine what kind of technological
progress we're gonna make in the next
ten years what are we gonna see what's
gonna happen how is it gonna change the
creator' economy how's it gonna how's it
gonna change you guys in what you make
next like what's gonna happen what are
people gonna see like am I even gonna
adapt to it am I even gonna want to
adapt to it am I am I gonna like be set
in my ways and be like it was better
back in my day when you had to make a
let's play with it with a screen
recorder and a camera we didn't have
this beam casting directly into their
eyeballs nonsense people weren't virtual
reality seing inside my recording room
we were in all on a couch together it's
[ __ ] but I know that I'm gonna keep
changing because for me life is change
you always change you always got to
change if you stay the same you're never
gonna get anywhere in life and like
everyone that wants to hold on to
something it never made sense to me that
whole mind said that you could stay the
same and you keep things controlled and
you hold on to what you have never made
sense to me
that's why I've always said you know I
didn't care if my channel died tomorrow
it's not that I didn't care about a
channel it's that you know if it does
I'm ready to move on if it does die or
if for some reason it does go away I am
ready to move on to something new
because I like the idea of the challenge
I like the idea of seeing what else I
can do of being forced into a
circumstance where I have to change and
I have to adapt and I have to do
something new and I have to see what
life is gonna throw at me and I have to
roll with it or else I'm just gonna end
up being rolled over like that's that's
the only real set rule there is is that
there will be change you have to adapt
or you die that's been the rule of life
since the beginning of it so yeah why
should I try to make it any different
and technology is just gonna make it
wildly different
I think that's that's definitely gonna
be something that's gonna be ingrained
in whatever I do next the the deep
appreciation of of technology and trying
to build something off of it and if I do
start a comedy or if I do do different
videos it'll be hello John John yeah if
it's me it'd be something to do with
technology because for me like
technology and advancing humanity and
making sure that humanity is always
moving forward like that system that's
just essential for me there there there
really is no other thing to do besides
that and making sure that mindset is
spread as far as implies the candy and
making sure that people's minds are
always pushing forward is essential all
right Bill Williamson what the hell you
going on about you've been trying to get
my attention for three goddamn episodes
now what do you want what do you want
bill the hell do you want been cooking
since horseshoe but you went kicked up
all that commotion at violent end
now we was preparing to rob the bank
there until you got involved and all
that nonsense and I don't know I just
feel like it's unfinished business that
wasn't my fault it was just one of them
things how come every time I get in
trouble I'm called a fool and an idiot
but when you get in trouble oh it's just
one of them things it's a good point
often yeah that's good point hit the
goddamn bank with us you really think
it's worth going back there four of us
can hit the bank easy but angle out of
you there will be loss we linger serious
no just local boys being rounded up and
pressed into action meaning if we go in
quick and quiet we can hit it just fine
if there's four of us I mean y'all think
it's worth the risk it's a bank Arthur
so is the take according to the fella I
met yes it's the end of the stock sales
plenty of money and plenty of people
milling about
all right now suppose it's worth taking
a look at least any case I need to
change out of these rags from gonna be
performing okay
so bill it's very work oh it is we put a
lot of research into this 100 so hmm
okay yeah I'll believe it when I see it
Bill Williamson let's go whoo mr. Morgan
Herr Strauss that man the debtor Thomas
dance
apparently he's dead dead well he didn't
seem very well his wife I believe he has
a wife and child
she even assumed the dead of course of
course then you can head up there and
collect he lent them a lot of money okay
gentlemen let's go rob ourselves a bank
what's the plan now
oh we're gonna send Karen on in ahead as
a distraction then we're just gonna rush
on in afterwards just a small bank and a
little town nothing that big in wave
security we just need to bring you along
as a insurance policy yeah sounds about
right yeah it sound about right all
right follow me okay while I'm in town
maybe I can get my beard trimmed up I
think it'll match my wave my hat
where is my hat where's my hat good sir
where's my hat hang on wait Kent I gotta
get my hat hang on guys I can't rob a
bank without my hat I really really
really cannot rob a bank without my hat
where's my hat
I got my hat yeah we got my hat have I
seen my hat hat have I seen my hat you
guys didn't take my bear hat did you you
wouldn't have taken my bear hat cuz
you'd be dead goddamn it
where's my hat I will abandon the game I
will or in a heartbeat a band of the
gang if it means that I get my hat back
am I on you gotta go into this mission
hatless you're gonna make me do that
you're gonna make me do that you sons of
tits I will stab you all in your sleep
that's where God will fine whatever
with me Vivian when it got a long road
ahead of us we're really gonna be going
all the way over to Valentine that's a
hell of a journey
alright you better entertain me with
some dialog I'm a professional is that
[Music]
good I can give you drunken harlot of
course lost little girl in the crowd
wants only you would want that with the
guards and the customers while you hit
the ball I thought you only brought me
four shirts
alright I'll hit the ball no no I got it
okay and that's it that's it I just
write what's up I mean it's um
that rude I can't talk to you they've
done you had a gourd yeah go we're going
all the way to Valentine's we're gonna
go in silence really I mean this is
beautiful
he's got an beautiful but I've said that
like 10 times now I gotta get something
to disable our ninja [ __ ] beautiful
which it is I mean we look good I mean
we look real good I won't deny we look
good but my god we are not moving okay
fine you know what screw this I'm going
around get out my way to get out my way
get out my way if you're not gonna jab
her at me you got it wait how can I talk
to these people
[Music]
we shot the place to help you did Morgan
me I played it cool up there
couple of pawn shops dealt with some oak
Driscoll's like I said you Missa
it's just one of them Saints I miss oh
I'm the prize idiot
well I don't know what to tell you
surprised you ain't already ripped me
about that dynamite again one mistake
and I'll never live it down just know I
got the lead on this one we'll see about
that
once things get going why aren't you and
lennier alone for this boys out of
trouble I ain't sure even linen can be
relied on the give his head
not after that night you do Adam
Valentine yeah I've been trying to
forget that but a little I remember on
me Danny and I before you searched takes
one to know one
yes we'll never learn it very much
better
whiskey oh wait till after the bank
yeah hey Lenny Lenny Lenny Lenny Manny
Joe how are you feeling about their
slanting well at first I thought it was
a bad idea but then I figured they all
turtley have been recently I mean why
the hell not
roll with I just told him we needed you
along I appreciate the confidence kid
and if we didn't rob this Bank
we really would be slipping tops like
that and you're one of us no down so
hope so
alright yes we're doing this then it did
well with that gang the shady Bell yeah
Thanks and I heard the rest of the memo
gone from there now so we must have sit
enough of a message I reckon so I lose
much sleep over them fellas
me neither they love nothing more than
Australia that word gonna happen not
through lack of trying
not to you good hole to that dynamite
come in real useful today if we can even
get near the bank without someone
recognizing us and raising here oh well
I have to see about that just keep okay
looks like we're actually here man that
was a long run wait is that Valentine
wait things look greener on this season
that's game
wait are the seasons in this game this
am I gonna see fall oh my god I want to
see fall I want to see small so badly I
miss fall I haven't seen fall in five
years I miss fall I'm his father
oh god I miss fall so badly
yeah it looks so much greener here I
don't remember it being this green I
remember it being desert like that cuz
it was rainy is it like the rainy season
or something like that that's so cool
if that's the case this goes deeper than
I ever thought it could possibly go oh
yeah no it was definitely way way way
okay you got okay
yeah ready all right go for it Karen you
got it all right keep it cool and follow
me fellers
oh I'm always cool look how cool I am my
coat
dude good bank robbers always wear coach
like this is that is that how this works
sure what's the deal here we never
decided is it lost little girl drunk
Marla oh it's got to be lost little girl
oh it's definitely gonna be lost girl
little girl lost even you long to save
the fallen women a Arthur
[Music]
you're ready get going good luck
gentlemen
we got this okay should I put my mask on
I do it anyway
oh god what happened to my gun okay
we're going
no wait if she's gotten real dad
don't you hear the door
okay I'm going for it I'm going for it I
didn't have to shout anything I thought
y'all we are kind of here for fun it is
a good time we'll admit this is fun get
it get it
open you better open a good beat come on
hurry up now any minute now
any minute now oh come on
alright don't lock me in here
God what get some crack them or blow
them up keep an eye
oh I can track as a cab I'll crack him
I'll crack him
I like cracking I like cracking fraud
but you better be quick oh I'll be quick
oh don't worry wanna see this I've never
cracked a case before I want to do that
hell yeah okay
[Music]
got it okay that was harder than I
thought but I think I figured it out I
figured it out I figured it on okay okay
this is slower but it's quiet
[Music]
we're getting there any more minutes I'm
getting good at this
give me give me give me give me give me
give me Oh big Hall organized rio5 even
if ago even if they come now this is a
good all oh yeah baby let me get one
more cuz I'm breathe okay okay okay okay
okay maybe I can give this last last one
good we gotta move last
okay okay got it got it got it got hell
yeah I don't know why I was
concentrating so hard on that but holy
[ __ ] this is so much money this is so
much money this is so much money it's so
much money I should rob banks more often
oh [ __ ]
wow he's good come on let's go okay easy
easy peasy no one knows no one needed to
go in the bank no one went from the bank
it's all good dude dude - dude - do
[Applause]
are they didn't know it was us
why not unknown okay let's go we can't
lose any of this mine can't lose his
money okay we can't lose the money I'm
riding what you think I'm doing them red
let me uh that's the carbine Lancaster
that's what I need
come on guys we got this it's EEZ sorry
sorry about it I'm ruined coming back to
Valentine anyway so no harm no foul
right whoa and ha boom oh you're going
up I didn't know you're growing up yeesh
can I make this chase cinematic Sal come
if I could even do anything cinematic
South nope I cannot
oh he's dead alright goodbye this is
cool this is cool this is the first time
we've done a crime and it felt like a
crime this is so cool
it was so tense I love this one yeah I
thought this is gonna be a like this
bank robber who's gonna be a little
boring but no oh my god
is anything but
Oh how many bullets see you need man
sorry horse he didn't mean that got you
okay okay okay you know we're all to the
point where we're getting like
self-driving cars right but horses
you can drive themselves why don't we
all go back to horses horses are pretty
cool have to do nothing I'm trying
nice oh damn it god damn it somebody
radio for help that you'll be happy even
if it did come with a heap of hay we
weren't at that camp where they were at
that camp
mrs. Downes what about mrs. Downes oh
that's right I stuff to do this I wonder
why this is associated with each other
that's weird but how much money did I
get how much money did I get so much
money but we got so much buddy what the
hell oh this is good I don't like this I
don't like the feel of this that was too
easy for how much money we could have
gone I don't have the money in my hand
and now I gotta go see a lady whose
husband died who was only trying to do
good in the world and I'm going to
collect a debt there oh I do not like
the sound of this the music's getting
sad too ah songs going bad here all my
ding dong the alarm bells for bad stuff
is happening it's always a high before a
very low
I'm not too sure I like how low it might
be going it's real somber that's all I
can say about that
hello mrs. downs oh hello Poochie
oh yes hello hey there good puppy oh hey
boy alright hello my husband's not cold
in the ground and you've come back here
aren't you
I nearly paid off what was owned your
husband knew the rules when he took that
money now I'm real sorry about the way
things turned out but he had a choice he
my fault about the way the world is he
didn't have a choice he was good and he
did good there wasn't no choice in that
and you as good as killed him yourself
and don't kid yourself you had a choice
you speak as if killing was something I
cared about you ever wonder about
eternity should I hope it's hot and
terrible mrs. downs otherwise I'll feel
I've been sold a false bill of goods now
please give me that money either you got
a lazy eye or lack of respect which is
it for ain't got no lazy eye no respect
for the likes of you well maybe when
your mother's finished mourning your
father I'll keep her in black on your
behalf you think on that poor well maybe
you shall sir and maybe other events
will transpire you best stick to them
books because mark my words on this
vengeance is an idiot's game how missus
down thank you for your punctuality next
to godliness isn't it that's cleanliness
I'll have to take your word on that good
day
I feel bad about that one that's not
good goddamn he really is the son of a
[ __ ] isn't he as much as I want to
empathize with him as much as me like a
good dad he's still a murderer still an
outlaw still exploiting people I mean as
much as he wants to say it like it is
business yeah I get it
at the same time heavy [ __ ]
I just love how interwove and everything
is everything is so connected so deeply
connected it's so much stored itself
hello horse that I abandoned it holy
[ __ ] those towers so much money there's
so much money I'm gonna buy all the
upgrades to camp I possibly can make oh
boy this cannot keep up this cannot keep
up something is gonna go bad at some
point here
hey wait the gang I thought the game
just got I thought the campus was
rolling in money here and whatever I'll
contribute I mean what am I gonna do the
money anyway I'm not gonna do anything
with it so I gotta give all my items you
being a good leader over there boss
[Music]
what about me I did it to boss
you remembering me you turn off the damn
music bam thank you so much I'm gonna
assume that I was named in person there
oh my god look at how good I am doing
and all of you are just sucking dick huh
I am obviously the best here because I
am frickin great we're gonna upgrade
everything to maximum upgrade ability
and you all are gonna be like Oh Arthur
you think Arthur for this [ __ ] cuz I did
it I'm here to help everybody all of you
are just trying to help yourselves Lulu
I'm here putting money in every day see
that rabbit all meat do you that rabbit
all me see that table that dog all meat
y'all suck let's have some fun I like
fire bottles that's a good one I don't
know if I can clean my gun there or
whatever but alright next in line I
don't know what that is Arthur wants a
map to plan journeys oh that's me I'm
Arthur a fast travel map wait that was
him I could have had fast travel this
entire time and all it took was
upgrading by 10 I didn't do that
alright well everyone's doing better off
now I guess whatever we'll get a horse
station sure why not then we'll even get
a boat I don't even know we're going to
do that's not any better that's what
okay I get I think yes I know that it's
just three sticks in the ground about
whatever boat get a boat I guess God
doesn't better do with our money I'll
get a boat
alright we got a boat everybody
everybody happy about the boat we got
you better be because I did it for you
cuz I'm a hero of this place I'm here
you deserve alright we're good to go
I hope you're happy everybody because I
did this and you all need to be thankful
for that score Miss Roberts maybe you'll
let me take you out sometime I don't
think so
I shall hey Batman go buy her something
decent teeth hmm yeah okay Abigail wait
are you flirting with John marcin's
woman hmm I don't care with that I don't
like you I never came to America until
there was a man there 17v grew up quick
in Vienna perhaps all right that's so
weird that you could just experience the
culture of the campus as a dog to
everybody okay Josiah that's right
Josiah wants to talk to me
all right Josiah you have my attention
oh you don't feel very part of the camp
do you do that that's not yours either
that's keyring like oh there you are I
know you think I'm just some effete
buffoon what a man of words are not of
action hardly a man at all
Wow I think slippery as an eel in an oil
slick but still a man because I think
I've I found something interesting yeah
have you ever robbed a stagecoach even
thought a course around a goddamn
stagecoach you know I and what's the
problem with stagecoaches
the armed man attempt to put a bullet in
your head
not quite the odds I mean is it worth
the robbing sometimes I know but well if
you'd like to come with me I can
introduce you to a new best friend and
he's he's going to give you all the
decent robbing stagecoaches a hot
blooded degenerate could require well I
could require a whole lot okay found my
horse you say all right I'll mount my
I don't know why I'm on my horse but
I'll mount my horse I know you have
friends but you won't like the way I
lead gotta get my hat where's my hat
give me my hat which one's my bad I
don't even remember which one's my bed
where's my bed that's my bed
okay that is definitely my bed please
tell me that I can get my hat please I
don't see a marker on the map but I'm
assuming that I can get my hat hat well
god what first bank robbery newspaper
scratch oh that's not my hat
goddamn it can i really not I can't
I can't get my hat god dammit life is so
painful they give me a hat and then they
just take it away from me they give me
my favorite hat and then I can't even
use my favorite hat god damn you damn
you all to hell I'll burn help y'all
burn in hell
what damn it damn it yeah whatever
[Music]
thanks for disappearing on us turn that
Shawn business by the way I'd done my
part each to their strengths dear boy
you know you boys should really watch
yourselves with those two families this
is a small town people talk I tried to
mention it to a saya but you know how he
is
anyway while they're off chasing their
pot of Confederate gold hidden at the
end of some rainbow let me present you
with something real so where exactly are
we going the train station the clerk
there Alden is quite a fellow very
informed on the comings and goings of
coaches around these parts ok alright if
you say so my good lad
hichy hichy this very few times when I
actually hits my horse I don't feel the
need to however if you say so I'll do so
can I get my repeater carbine please
nope nope like oh yeah no weapons in
this town the one time I remember I
actually don't need weapons
Jelani come on we doing there well what
would we I'm not scary this is my big
beard I don't even have my bear hat I
can't possibly be intimidating or
endearing anyway I'd take that out on a
first date no take that on a nice tinder
date seal the deal ok hello I'm gonna
stand here not intimidating in any way
at all I'm actually gonna creep forward
like this don't mind anything times are
tough my missus is a bad woman
were terrible wait you just got cut
again they Rick and they just invented a
new horses carriage will be the end of
us they've been saying that nonsense
since they invented the wheel the
witness of bosses no my comrades here
and I are greatly discouraged from the
adequate fulfillment of our duty a
discouraged man is no man at all Alda no
man at all my friend author here as a
present for you Oh me yes I don't have a
present for you do you remember me I
paid a lot of bounties for murder there
you go
this one's a tip is one of us a fellow
man of distinction distinct I do stink
indeed perfect timing I think you'll
like this one Jose ah it'll be coming
south down the river road through silt
water strand uh-huh thank you all thank
you very much oh and Jose ah if you were
Arthur or ever out strawberry way ask
for my colleague there feller called
Hector he's also one of the what did you
call us again discouraged men although
that's it discouraged man I like that
well goodbye Alden or should I say we
are all so fancy here rat
on River Road through silt water
stranding ship okay I think I know a
good spot to wait follow me why do you
talk like you're got a spasm in your
diaphragm I wonder if like coz that
whole like transatlantic thing that's
not quite transatlantic but like I feel
like just people's desires to talk fancy
I just came out of nothing I guess there
was trying to sounded distinct from one
another somehow never works really just
sounded like a pompous douche most of
the time no matter what way you tried to
do it that's why I'm proud to have a
Cincinnati an accent
the most basic and non special accent
that's okay Oh God why would he say that
unless something went wrong something's
gonna go wrong we man of distinction who
are discouraged it's gonna go wrong here
we are all right if you say so
nice spot my good okay they're safe
sorry
what we think well according to this the
loot is located in a strongbox which is
in the back I'll put on a little
formants and you can scurry around open
the strongbox and relieve them of the
goodies how do i open the strongbox
without threatening someone to open it
for me this should work I'm hoping
complete silence won't be necessary
but you're going to wish you had your
earplugs this is damson oh very good old
and very good like you normally do I'm
gonna try to do it but I don't have my
bear hat I'd be much better at sneakin
if I had my bear got it
wait no no oh they're gone I thought
they were coming this way
[Music]
okay I'm good I'm good sorry pardon me
okay you do that what a scupper mean
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
miss Thompson Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry for the interruption everyone else
on this it was like holy [ __ ] I can't
even remotely give a [ __ ] about what's
up dude
how much money did I get I don't even
know I have no idea hope it was a good
amount
hey troll Annie hey tree Luna hate
wriggle oh no that's how I do it baby
that's how I do not finesse all over
room you know how I is I got the most
finesse in the West that's what they say
hell what the hell why oh my god alien
ok I guess we're golden from time to
time see you soon look we're not gonna
talk about that I think we got abducted
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure was just
kind of ducted by aliens I'm not a
hundred percent but I got I got like a
lot of pain a pro block pain going on
and I don't know what to do Trelawney
okay we're gonna pretend like that
didn't happen all right so we got it but
go back to Jose
[Applause]
[Laughter]
fishing on my map but we gotta go
and because it's last mission
so we're heading in Hosea
oh yeah the brick water the breakwall
the bravely the Brit wave okay I gotta
stop do with that so we're gonna make
our way over to the great wave this
place meet with Hosea and then we're
gonna finish off probably the dynamics
between the two feuding families that's
what I would guess that this particular
adventure is gonna do now I don't know
if I'm welcome on this place but I think
I am I think we left on good terms even
though I stole their horses whose
mysterious group of people stole our
horses looked a lot like you but he had
a mask on there's no way I could
possibly tell if it was actually you
also I want to see Hosea really really
what we didn't even hit anything that
time this seems like this games trying
to play the joke too hard I ain't gonna
laugh at that
hey funny you ain't funny where is this
mozar pose an ayah pose Simba mohos
Dumbo oh hello how are you hello ha
please come in sir I already did thank
you
this way sir you have an incredible
voice gentleman to see you ma'am it's me
I am a gentleman friend the other liquor
vendor hello welcome we were just
playing cribbage
pather Morgan mrs. Katherine Braithwaite
nice to see you again
apparently so this one he is big and as
dumb as he looks
well he's surely big but his
intelligence as a matter of some
conjecture some say he is as dumb as he
looks but I think well he's not quite
that so these are the boys going to
caligo hall yes we can take care of that
for you but one hates to be course there
is the question of money oh we've got
money mr. Matthews paper bonds metal she
ain't gonna pay you with a certified
cheque you Yankee numbskull hey
childbirth just the most beautiful
marathoner it seems a lady can birth
monkeys after all they are having a
great conversation over there and I
didn't need any input on that whatsoever
hey Shawn you're more than on time I
don't know why I like you things like
you know I don't even know what we're
doing what are we doing why are we here
what are we doing what are we doing are
we gonna blow something up what what the
hell is in the wagon
Oh moon charity let's get outta here
all right I can't see any boys in there
okay everything I have that's on a horse
he showed that silver spill down his
truck pull it clean out of his ass
that smoke [ __ ] okay so what she God
is doing at the grave place she wants us
to torture tobacco fields said there had
rained in weeks around here what
using that back there moonshine horns
faster than kerosene that stuff instead
of befitting she did no taking his elbow
Boyd Boyd fits my boot up y'all know
just naughty old [ __ ] these families go
go stashed somewhere he reckons them in
the MA for sticking it to rich folks
where hey rich folks they're really very
soft bloody money at the end of all this
Jose knows what he's doing dosey doe the
master Feniger of Lawton
so far we've destroyed the break waits
till 3:00 to send the shiny back they
were saying oh man graves double
security after that business at the
saloon just robbed their horses wagons
go we know what they're all the time we
sold these work equipment they wrote
specially no to take on all that extra
muscle just leave it to me
well you can talk a dog off a meat wagon
I don't even know what that phrase means
but all right sure I still talk to you
know prepare lean on okay thought we're
gonna have a nice chitchat for whatever
cuz we don't need to well I guess we're
out of conversation for the rest of this
huh
you said you could talk the dog off a
meat wagon whatever the hell that means
but you can't carry out a conversation
for the rest of this journey yeah
whatever
good morning to you also there's some
weird level of trust that's happening
with this old lady and I feel like even
if she is a sassy old lady like Hosea
like she probably should have gotten him
killed long ago and if that's not what
we're setting up for right now then I
don't know what she's doing
also where's was it in black Beatrice
Beatrice black I can't remember she was
so cool BB I'm gonna call her BB baby
was so cool god damn it CBB again you
got to see your gun because there's no
way someone like that the character that
cool is this gonna come and go like that
alright excuse us we're gonna plow
through here
maybe what what what what
what's happening oh I'll be down here
just gotta fill in my own dialog I guess
what's the earthers point of view what I
got here
nice ankles Sean okay I guess we're just
gonna be stylin here
whatever whatever have you oh this is
some interesting all right hello we're
back again good friends I don't know how
we're gonna get away with torching all
of your tobacco but uh we're gonna try
our best so the heads up just a warning
I guess yeah yeah okay
all right hello we mean no harm in the
middle of the night how you doing oh boy
I there was a ting ting at the saloon
what you talkin about
well I'm delivering the supplies you're
not the usual driver you want to pawn
the friend yeah we drop called from
Donnie Carla in Ireland you don't say
yeah he said she'd understand
now some kind of incident at the saloon
in town I was told to bring this up here
ask no questions I'll tell you no lies
sort the business at and before the
officials got there okay okay grab this
way I'll show you how to get there
oh thank you flame there have a drink
sure
Tennessee's ankles sub me right here
something feel I feel like something
about this game broke mine is connemara
but fine under less my people come from
Scott what does that make me what does
that make me the guy in the back gotta
hide me under this the guy whose head I
think I can see the top of poking out my
god so I can barely keep track all these
deliveries coming in yeah and they said
they was looking for our drivers in town
while he jumped at that chance
I never been better to take a bit of
honest walk out of bed so you folks been
having a higher time of it have you yeah
mr. Gray's got a heap of problems right
now with another family around here
bunch of covetous lowdown trying to
sabotage his lively discussed kid man
taro taro I'm sorry to hear that a
mission seems like you definitely
deserve that drink you don't know that
happen yeah don't in there
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what I was really trying there I was
really trying let me pick this guy up
you waito waito waito it was dark wait
it was dark it was this dark we came in
at the door no good here - got these
things ready okay okay sure I'm gonna
deal with the fields themselves oh hell
yeah
give me some thankfully rain and that
old barn over there should go up like a
torch how many these boys you think you
need it should do it look once they get
wind of us there'll be no turning back
so move quickly
of course rebel stop boy was born at
Elmira houses burn
yeah all right ooh I like this mission
okay I'm super down to this one on the
left
you say okay all right take care of the
fella you got them easy enough Oh
sploosh sploosh a blue to this boost
like ever sploosh sploosh those Unidos
give a solution must blue shares clues
there Liz blue shinier - she - yes blue
she'd do she'd get discs loose get his
plush you want blues here little fur you
have al over this one here loose
no one could hear me solution in the
middle of this tobacco field just boosts
your loss boost their service blue see
enough don't listen to miss pollution
sorry I spilled a little little sploosh
right behind you real quick crash the
board resolution oh shoot not supposed
to talk got some good solutions
hey you don't see me a solution do you
stealth bouche alright you uh you don't
mind me spoofing over here real quick
glass roof blue suppressor the wind
silence of the sploosh is over here and
finished off with one grant sploosh to
get me top of their field right here
sploosh oh hell yeah
all right Shawn abducts motion oh that
guy looks like he's in deserving of a
swoosh let me go sploosh him in the neck
never mind you got him oh you get it oh
you sploosh it up okay whatever you see
there fire bottles and sploosh
whoa well I didn't turn out as well as I
thought it was didn't know the power of
my arm was both overwhelming and
underwhelming oh god damn it how hard is
splooshed this area to maximum spruce
äj-- get him before you I'm gonna get
him before you I'm gonna get him before
he I'm gonna get him for you you okay
thank you
man I've never seen a man's blue squat
like you until they invent video cameras
and I can wash myself sploosh sploosh
all day all right here we go we're sad
some sort of like a trajectory our Andy
[Music]
don't please rally didn't get it it it
it it it it it it it okay is it going
where do we got company is this my good
gun I don't know if it's my good gun all
right Shawn where are you good God these
guys don't die from one of these all
this gun so slow down sad mother gun I'm
just gonna go pistols for this one
because I can't be bothered with doing
all this nonsense
there we go Oh Mary you
damn shut his hat off Adam all right
what are we doing man what are we doing
yeah I suppose we can try man
wish I had my lever-action rifle
surprise surprise huh why would that
told you to do a job and then you got to
do the job so stop complaining about the
job whoa where are they I don't see him
got one apparently now this is a pretty
destructive piece of quests that we're
doing here whoa [ __ ]
see if the payroll was actually in there
hurry up take this one done Sean got any
minute now there you go
yeehaw indeed okay go back through the
fire that seems like a good idea
geez they're not gonna be able to
recover from this one are they it was
like a finishing blow for this family
then don't you think
damn Sean's a good shot you didn't used
to be let me practice oh god why not
hold on when it's not comedic Lee time
come on go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go it's okay it's okay you're a
good horse that's a good boy that's a
good boy that's a good boy you're not as
good as my horse but whatever
yeah this whole town got wrecked by us
walking in here I think they might
suspect that maybe something's going on
maybe something a little bit problematic
with these newcomers they are so
quote-unquote helpful
[Music]
sure interesting a photo just put us
into the middle of here Oh Hosea riding
that there's some money at the end of it
there better be no head on back to camp
you coming oh yeah I'm gonna camp
you're not gonna camp why wouldn't I go
to camp that's where we need to be
anyway
I'll get back to it no matter what got
to get my hat yeah we did good that was
a fun one I mean I screwed it up there
in the middle but you know it's on fire
I just want to feel what it was like to
be lit on fire yeah that's quite a
tobacco hi they got going on there
everyone's gonna be feeling good for
miles and then get horrible cravings
we're back we did it we're such
champions can I have my hat oh hell yeah
wow that wasn't worth it oh that was
barely worth it that's a terrible that's
a terrible take was that even really
worth it the answer is no the answer is
a big old no oh that better not be my
cthe at wants some help there please
tell me that's not mica oh god it's mica
alright screw you I'm getting my hat I
don't know where my hat went but I'm
going to get my hat oh I'm sorry you
sleeping here at pardon me I'm sorry
where is my bed get me my hat my bed
Yuja mica don't say a goddamn word to me
I swear to God I will stab you change
clothing and give me my hat there's my
hand is my hat there's my hat where's I
was about to say I was about to say I
was about to say I better all right so
that will do it for this episode of Red
Dead Redemption - how far in the story
are we now that is a good question we
nope that's not what I'm
oh I haven't technically saved
good great progress that's what I'm
looking for all right okay
but this is awesome I still love it I
still love this so much this game is
super fun them thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think down in the comments below expect
more Red Dead Redemption very soon
should be in the set schedule that I
imagine it will be so take care and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye